this is a production of Cornell
University
but I will I apologize for those of you
who were here yesterday that i will
repeat one or two things but i try and
keep the repetition to a minimum because
what i want to talk about today is is
global atmospheric change and how we how
we might be able to adapt crops to that
particularly with respect to rising
carbon dioxide and also try and explain
why i think there is mileage in trying
to make those adaptations i should say
at the outset that i can only give this
talk because of the work done by past
graduate students lisa rains worth
carbon aki will hae jin wan jou and
postdocs justin McGrath and Venkat
Srinivasan and also faculty colleagues
Donnell and Praveen Kumar you've all
helped doing this work Owen Darren Drury
who was a postdoc working with me as
well um so this is where I work be
instituted genomic biology at the
University of Illinois in front of that
are the morrow plots the oldest
agricultural experiment outside of
rottenness did england and i just wanted
to show this sort of connection that we
have so much of the filled work i
showing you is done very close to this
location so a lot of the work shows an
interplay between lab modeling and
filled work and i hope i hope that would
be a parent so what are we concerned
about whatever is debated there is no
debate about the fact that the carbon
dioxide atmosphere in the carbon dioxide
concentration in the atmosphere is
rising and its really rising at a quite
unprecedented rate in geological history
at the present time most of our crop
ancestors evolved in the average co2
concentration of the last ten million
years which was about 220 parts
million today we are over 400 parts per
million so we're we're close to doubling
what those crop ancestors evolved
evolved in um if we look at what is
driving climate change in the atmosphere
then co2 of course is the biggest
contributor to this but also methane
nitrous oxide halocarbons are an
important part of this and one that's
often overlooked is tropospheric ozone
most greenhouse gases are hetero Tomic
molecules carbon dioxide nitrous oxide
but ozone also behaves as a hetero Tomic
molecule and it absorbs infrared
radiation so it is a part of the
greenhouse effect when it's in the
troposphere in the stratosphere of
course it's important in absorbing UV
radiation and our activities of greatly
increased ozone in the troposphere and
that ozone is also toxic to plants so it
has a direct effect as well as an
indirect effect other aspects aerosols
actually cause a cooling effect increase
in cloud cover as we warm up the
atmosphere as a feedback effect as well
but overall the anthropogenic effect is
strongly positive leading to increased
energy in the troposphere so that is
predicted to lead to on average a 122
degrees C temperature rise by 2050 now
although precipitation is rising drought
is also rising because with rising
temperature we have more of a /
transpiration also the with increased
energy in the atmosphere events become
more intense more if you like chaotic so
this will probably also lead to more
or drought events we think that surface
ozone today averages about 50 parts per
billion in the northern hemisphere we
think that will rise to between 60 to 90
parts per billion depending on whether
really controls proposed by a number of
companies really sorry countries bite or
whether they don't a lot of this rises
actually south of us in the tropics
particularly in east asia as well but
these are really if you like three major
four major global change issues that our
crops will have to face by 2050 and
indeed facing already because you know
as i said the crop ancestors evolved in
the co2 concentration that is very
different to the one we have today and
indeed tropospheric ozone we think
pre-industrial ii was probably no more
than 10 parts per billion today it
averages 50 parts per billion we
frequently see hundred parts per billion
in central Illinois and today so so what
is the problem what are the impacts of
rising co2 and how might we adapt to
rising co2 the other three things I want
to try and look out so again as I showed
yesterday are four major crops globally
in terms of if you like these are the
crops that provide over two-thirds
directly or indirectly of human calories
so amazed is number one and it's c4 so
it has a different response to rising
co2 rice and wheat on the other hand the
c3 very important as direct sources of
human calories and then saw a very
important protein source so those last
three are all c3 crops and should
respond very strongly to rising carbon
diox--
side and as I showed yesterday we're
responsible for all the United States
produces almost a third of the world's
soy production a very significant part
of wheat production and over a third of
of maize production now if we look at
how we're improving the yield of these
crops then if we take the historical
trajectory and we say well we ought to
better continue that into the future
then we would end up at this point by
2050 but what FAO and John Foley's group
at Minnesota have projected is that this
is what we will need by 2050 so we
really need to get onto this trajectory
because staying on this one will result
in significant shortages significant
price increases that will affect the
poorest in the global community I should
also point out that I've just added on
here cassava cassava is a crop which
many many smallholders poor communities
particularly in sub-saharan Africa
depend on and I think these you'd
improvements which we show for our major
crops are not apparent in some of these
might what we might call minor crops but
actually extremely important crops for
those those communities we we've failed
to improve those at the rate that we're
improving our our best crops or rather
shouldn't say our best crops out if you
like our top crops the ones which
particularly matter to the developed
world um the picture there was a little
bit worse because if we look at these
rice and wheat for example sames true
soy that if we look at during the Green
Revolution years then we were improving
average global yields by thirty to forty
percent per decade so a huge change in
global food supply
the this really eliminated the major
famines that have been seen in the 1960s
oh so the Green Revolution had a huge
impact at that stage but as we move away
we see that wheat and rice really the
yield improvements are are declining and
in fact in the last decade we wasn't
improved at all and rice is now in
single figures now I just want to put up
an equation developed by John Monteith
at rothamsted which explains at least
why we may be running out of steam with
genetic yield potential either eula crop
will achieve when it's grown under
optimum conditions so no diseases no
pests adequate water and adequate
nutrients and what this tells us is that
the yield of a crop will depend on how
much sunlight is available for
photosynthesis by the crop and i should
say here were just interested in the
visible sunlight because that is all
plants use in photosynthesis how good
they are capturing that light so what is
the efficiency with which they capture
it during the growing season how
efficient are they are then converting
that captured light into biomass and
then how good are they are partitioning
that biomass into the parts of the crop
we care about so the grain of wheat the
grain of rice and these are just data
for soybean crop on our University farm
modern soybean crop growing on not
growing with irrigation but growing on a
deep Midwest soil where there's plenty
water available and basically what we
see is that interception efficiency and
partitioning efficiency are already
remarkably high and the these are in the
case of rice and wheat these are
products of the Green Revolution that's
really what we changed in rice
we partitioning efficiencies went up
from thirty percent to sixty percent
interception efficiencies improved as
well and if we really you know look at
these these are pretty well hitting on
their biological maxima so there isn't
really much more we can squeeze out of
those but so what i should point out is
this number conversion efficiency and
this is really a very good number for
most crops a three percent is only a
third of the theoretical value so
conversion efficiency photosynthesis is
one thing weathers an opportunity still
to improve on yield potential genetic
your potential so how does co to tie
into this what is co to do to crop
plants well for a theoretical point of
view the only way a plant can sense co2
the truck that co2 changes at the levels
that we're dealing with if you put a
plant in ten percent co2 then you change
its pH and all sorts of things start to
happen but if you just for example
elevate co2 from where we are today to
where we think would be in the latter
half of the century there are only
really two ways a plant can sense this
one is the key carboxylase in
photosynthesis rubisco um is not co2
saturated and it also catalyzes a
process called photorespiration co2
increase the saturation of rubisco and
it inhibits that oxygenation reaction
which leads to photorespiration so it
sensed at rubisco it's also sense that
the level of stomata and how this
happens is not fully understood but
stomata will close um in response to
rising co2 and we
we don't know how much of that is really
a direct effect but if you strip off the
epidermis of many plants float them on
water subject them to elevated co2 you
will see a closing response now was
thought for many years that respiration
was also affected by co2 people took out
there some of you may be facilit
familiar with like or gas exchange
systems or other gas exchange systems
they they put these on plants elevated
the co2 in the chamber and they saw a
suppression of respiration but we were
very suspicious that what's going on is
it's very difficult to prevent co2 from
leaking out of these systems completely
prevented and so what we eventually
managed to do was get a manufacturer who
could actually give us a differential
oxygen system this was about a year of
work but so that we could instead
measure oxygen uptake which is much more
of a challenge because there is so much
more oxygen in the atmosphere but but
when we eventually got this working to
our satisfaction the postdoc in the lab
who was doing it was saying well I'm
doubling co2 or not seeing anything so I
said well put through 1% co2 and see
what happens he pulls through 1% co2 and
we saw her absolutely nothing so we
publish that in plant physiology and I
think the idea that co2 is suppressing
respiration has gone away now so at
least we can work sorry
we can simplify what really a plant can
see in terms of co2 now so at the level
of rubisco what co2 is doing is co2 of
course is the substrate for conversion
of I uvp to two molecules of phosphor
glycol eight in the calvin cycle but
oxygen also reacts catalyzed by Rubisco
because that's why there's the O on the
end of Rubisco to produce glycolate if
glycol eight is produced then the plant
recycles that back to PGA but in doing
so it loses a carbon dioxide it consumes
a great deal of the NADPH and ATP
generated by the light reactions so it
imposes an inefficiency on the overall
photosynthetic process if you elevate
co2 you do two things you increase the
saturation of rubisco with co2 and you
competitively inhibit this oxygenation
reaction so that that is why glasshouse
growers it's worth their while elevating
their tomato tomato crop with co2
because they get a high yield precisely
because of this mechanism so it's harder
when it comes to fill crops though to
assess what co2 will do and so a lot of
the information we have comes from
chamber systems greenhouses controlled
environments and also small chambers put
over crops in the field but when you do
this even in the field situation you're
changing a lot of things you're lowering
the light level you're raising
temperature a little bit you're raising
humidity you're completely authoring
coupling with with the movement of the
air and you've got edge effects because
often the crop around the edges of this
has been knocked down and so lights
coming in from the side
and so we were really basing much of our
prediction on what would happen on crops
on very artificial systems that monsanto
or syngenta would never use plots this
size to decide whether their latest
transgene is is doing anything they want
an open crop field many of them to do
this and yet we are basically predicting
our future on experiments much smaller
much simpler than industry would ever
use for its business model so when I
moved to Illinois there was a chance
there with particularly with the
University farm and a big engineering
school to do something different and
this was something actually first
developed froze work with ozone and
atmospheric pollutants by andrew macleod
in the UK and then was taken up by
Brookhaven National Lab when I worked
there in the early 90s and then when I
moved to Illinois there was a chance to
really refine that which is what we did
and well what the engineers did I didn't
do it but but basically what these
systems do is that here we have a
soybean crop we do the same thing in
maize and also this has been done with
wheat and rice we've given our design
two groups in China which have now done
this very successfully with rice but
basically what happens is if the wind is
coming in this direction it sensed here
and co2 is released on the upwind side
it's feathered so that most is released
immediately upwind and then less as you
go to the sides and it's stepped
according to the wind speed as well in
the center we have a co2 analyzer and
infrared analyzer to check that the
algorithms doing the right thing and if
it is over it back sat off if it's under
it releases more and so he can see a
test of the system we switch it on at
this point and we're target is 550 parts
per million
and it it gets within plus or minus ten
percent of that target for about ninety
six percent of the time over the growing
season this is an infrared image or
sorry this is an infrared image and of
course as I said co2 causes partial
stomatal closure so the plants are
transpiring less they're losing less he
latent heat therefore they get warmer
and so you can see that it's warmer
within the ring and that's fairly
uniform compared to the outside now um
one of my former students and one of my
former postdocs both went away from
Illinois and then came back as faculty
and they're now doing their own
experiments in this system and Andrew
leaky is developed a rainout shelter
system where actually his this deploys
at night when we get about a two-thirds
of our rainfall in fact in the Corn Belt
due to convection or storms so if rain
if the thing senses rain it deploys a
shelter which collects the rain in the
gutter pipes are away from the site and
he imposes a drought here Carla's
developed an open air heating system so
he can raise the temperature of the crop
within these rings as well so we've now
got co2 drought and temperature combined
so within the experiment we've got those
added on these rings about 20 meter
diameter so gives you over 300 square
meters of crawl so you can do a lot of
things with with that that you can't do
with a small system so you can look at
everything from gene expression so the
final yield harvested with a small plot
combine we've so we have four of these
in soybean and replicated in maislin co2
for an elevated ozone for looking at the
combination and then
controls and then we have split plots
with the temperature and drought
treatments we've also looked at a range
of cultivars in there as well although
for most breeders 26 is way too small to
really do any breathing project but you
could replicate this technology out too
much larger areas so what did we find
when we did this under the open air well
and i should say this has also been done
with wheat this was an experiment in
arizona this was an experiment in japan
and they've happy more of those around
the world but to too few i believe so
this is this shows soybean and wheat
data from different chamber experiments
and so you can fit a line to those
against co2 but this is what we found in
our face experiment because that's just
one co2 level but basically we're
findings what we see under open air
conditions is about half of what have
been reported on averaging chamber
conditions and with maze the picture was
even worse that this is the projection
from chambers and of course many of
these plants are grown in but they're
all pretty well grown nearly all grown
in pots and this is what we see in the
open air so no stimulation at all and
we've done this now over over ten years
we still haven't seen the yield increase
so Lisa Ainsworth looked at this in more
detail that was published in 2006 by
2008 there were twice as many face
experiments to draw on and she showed
again that what you see on in the open
air the nearest proxy to a farmer's
field was only half of what was expected
it's the modelers I think are still not
convinced about results and even in the
latest IPCC they're suggesting the rise
co2 will rescue us from the problems of
rising temperature and and drought I I
don't subscribe to that view and I think
we if there's doubt about it we should
be trying to look at how we could adapt
to it if we don't need it that would be
great but if we do it'll be too late if
we don't start doing something now so if
we look at go back to John Monteith's
equations what we see is indeed
conversion efficiency at the crop level
is increased and that place through to
yield but it's only about half of what
we think we should get so how might we
adapt to that rising co2 and try and get
the kind of yield increase we think we
should obtain and again we this is
something we started when I was working
on the project but Lisa Ainsworth has
now taken this much further and what
we're doing here is looking at genetic
variation in response and so if we look
at seed yield a range of cultivars we
can see that this basically means no
response but up here we've got cultivars
that are clearly responding more
strongly so it appears there are some
genetics there that could be exploited
to adapt the crop but really to do this
you would need a mutt if you like a much
larger face system and you probably need
you needed in different locations
because we're pretty well in the center
of the soybean growing area but there's
plenty of soybean grown in Minnesota
plenty grown south of us we're growing
season lengths conditions are quite
different but it does suggest that this
is something that could well be
exploited one of the major issues is
really that around this rubisco issue so
we know from theory
what should happen which should be about
a thirty percent yield increase and we
can sometimes see there than chamber
experiments but in practice we're
getting a lot less so as I mentioned co2
is if you like suppressing
photorespiration and enhancing co2
uptake but temperature has the opposite
effect temperature makes Rubisco less
specific so as temperature increases
Rubisco becomes less able to
discriminate between oxygen and co2 and
photorespiration goes up and if you you
model this from rubisco kinetics put
that into a crop canopy what you see is
that this is the actual gain you get
with temperature sorry this is the
actual photosynthesis at the canopy
level this is what you could get if you
eliminated photorespiration and that
gain that difference becomes much bigger
with rising temperature so we've got two
things going on rising co2 and rising
temperature working against each other
now one way in which this could be
overcome synthetically is for example
were c4 photosynthesis is one of those
if we could make these crops c4 then we
could overcome this problem another way
and maureen hansen and i both been
involved in this area is that
cyanobacteria the ancestors of the
chloroplasts also have these bodies
called car boxes homes where which
contain their rubisco they actively take
up bicarbonate into their selves and
they also um will hydrate any co2 as
well so that out here you have a high
concentration of bicarbonate and no
carbon dioxide in this body called the
car Boxer so
they have carbonic anhydrase which
catalyzes the conversion of bicarbonate
to co2 so there's a very high
concentration of co2 here which the
Rubisco can take up because there's a
high concentration of co2 they do not
have photorespiration so there's an
active effort now to try and engineer
the system into the chloroplast so that
would be one way of dealing with this
justin mcgrath who's been working with
maureen and myself or modeling this
system has developed a diffusion
reaction model which really looks at all
these components and the sequence in
which this would ideally be engineered
but basically what he shows is in theory
if you could put this in to a crop plant
like soybean you could get almost a up
to a sixty percent increase in co2
uptake now um we'll hey working with Tom
Clemente IAM myself put in just one sign
a bacterial gene whose function is still
really unknown but it there's quite a
lot of evidence that it appears to
improve co2 access to rubisco and so
we'll put so we'll using soybean
transform with this one gene showed that
photosynthesis was indeed increased seed
mass was increased and these are filled
trials one of the most important
findings he made was that the maximum
efficiency of light limited
photosynthesis went up and this was
statistically significant and there's
only really three ways in which this is
possible you have a different Rubisco
which seems highly unlikely because the
large subunit at least is doesn't have
multiple forms
there's more oxygen which again sorry
less oxygen which again is extremely
difficult because there's twenty one
percent outside so inside it's probably
twenty nine nine percent the only other
way is to have more co2 at rubisco and
so this seemed good evidence that that
was what was happening just mention of
course not everything is predictable and
I showed examples yesterday with pests
of soybean when the other things we see
with and this was a bit of a shock was
that under elevated co2 but I hope it's
apparent there and it the crop is green
at the end of the growing season when
it's yellow outside and then in fact it
should have been the other way round
because the crops warmer he accelerates
development and it should have gone
yellow inside before it was green
outside and in fact the the engineer at
the site I was telling him tell me when
it goes yellow inside because I wanted
to take a picture of it and I kept
calling him every morning and he said no
no and eventually sheepishly said I
think his green inside but so I said oh
that can't be possible so I went out
there and sure enough it was green
inside the ring and yellow outside so so
by boosting photosynthesis and
carbohydrates supply it appears that
we've delayed senescence of of the crop
because this crop is genetically
identical you can see it's all in the
same field now this was very intriguing
because what we then found was these are
the track these are the wild-type
soybean same generation as these ones
which were transformed and at the end of
the season boosting photosynthesis
appeared to delay senescence so that was
another very interesting parallel
they these Tran transgenic plants
appeared just like the wild-type ones
give them more co2 sorry I move on from
this but one of the ways which we could
adapt the plant to rising co2 is exactly
around this issue of rubisco that if we
um look at the response of
photosynthesis to the co2 inside the
leaf so we're eliminating asta mottle
effect in this diagram what we see is
that as we increase co2 photosynthesis
increases rapidly then it reaches a
transition point where it rises more
slowly what is happening here is that
you're saturating the carboxylation
reaction of rubisco and then when you
get to this point you now become limited
by the supply of ru vp not directly by
the supply of co2 but not sure I have
managed to do that
so so but you can see there's still
arise here and the reason for this is
although are you BP is limiting because
you're increasing co2 your progressively
inhibiting the oxygenation reaction so
more of that limiting supply of IU BP is
being used in photosynthesis and less in
photo aspiration now if we M what we
tend to find is a current co2 levels so
if at a given stomatal conductance what
will happen is as we increase
photosynthesis the co2 concentration
inside the leaf will draw because
photosynthesis is removing co2 the stowe
mates are limiting that co2 so inside
the leaf you have lower co2 than outside
at this point inside and outside of the
same and what we typically find this
point the operating point is very close
to this transition and that makes sense
the leaf is optimized its investment in
rubisco versus apparatus for
regenerating um I uvp but now if we move
out to an elevated co2 situation we've
unbalanced this that we've now got we've
got far more rubisco than we need and
we're limited entirely by the apparatus
for regeneration of our ubp so in theory
what we could do is we could decrease
rubisco and if you like we could have
the same photosynthetic rate but be more
nitrogen you sufficient because rubisco
is about twenty-five percent of the
nitrogen in the leaf so is a lot of
nitrogen or we could use that resource
instead to increase capacity for a
generation of I ubp and have for the
same amount of nitrogen have even more
co2 fixed
now of course a question you might ask
is well does the plant know this if you
grow it under elevated co2 does it
acclimate in this way and these are data
that carbon aki took during his PhD work
where indeed the plant seems to know a
little bit of this and what he found was
there was a decrease in this initial
slope and the slight rise in the plateau
but it was no any enough to reach the
theoretical game so yeah I should so um
so one of the other things we looked at
was this issue of regeneration and Jing
one Jew who was a graduate student in
the lab at the same time as Carl I work
with me on developing a complete model
of photosynthesis where we represented
the whole system by a series of link
differential equations that we
eventually got to replicate what the
leaf was doing in terms of co2 uptake in
in vivo and this just shows some of the
classic responses we see if you like in
one of these cuvettes this just shows
that we could simulate these responses
with with the model so these dynamic
responses we could then use the system
to basically optimize investment so we
could say well apply if you like an
evolutionary algorithm to say okay where
should we be investing to regenerate ru
vp more efficiently and it picked out in
particular this one enzyme s BPA's but
there are a number of other changes that
suggested fb pas as well fbp outlays all
of which we're now looking at in
particularly in tobacco but probably
will test in soy be and my colleague
Christine rains in England did this with
tobacco here are plants in the
glasshouse we put those out in our soy
face experiment and could replicated in
in the field
and one things we found though was that
I'll skip over this was that under
elevated co2 the response was even
greater and that got us intrigued you
know because it fits in with the theory
I showed you that it should be greater
under elevated co2 so one of the other
things we did went back to with the
model was to say well it was curious
that s BPA's is a really very small
amounts of the total protein in the leaf
would be in theory be very easy for a
plant to evolve more s BPA's at a very
low cost so we reran the model up to 20
parts per per million per billion per
million sorry the concentration under
which we think the crop ancestors
evolved and we sorry we looked at flux
control and this was in the model and it
suggested well s BPA's would invert
would have no control over CO 2 fixation
under those conditions but at 390 ppm it
would have a strong control at 700 it
would be even more and rubisco will be
moving in the opposite direction so that
was consistent with what we saw in these
experiments I just very briefly
mentioned this but another thing that we
also have done with modeling is rubisco
appears to have a trade-off that this
specificity factor I wear plant if you
like we think that plants have evolved
to become very obviously very specific
for co2 against the very strong oxygen
background so that we find that crop
plants tend to have a specificity of 90
in in favor of co2 but as you go out to
sea for plants whether abisko is in a
high co2 environment or bacteria where
they might be an anaerobic environment
specificity drops but catalytic rate
increases so the thinking is that to get
tighter binding um catalytic rate has to
drop so there's a trade-off and to cut a
short a long story short what we found
was that you there should be an optimum
at any co2 concentration what we found
was that that optimum was a specificity
of about 90 a pre and rather the 2 20
ppm in which the plants probably evolved
but today it's much lower so there'd be
a big advantage in if you like getting
in a foreign rubisco which might have a
lower specificity but a higher k count
and indeed we model this amaranthus
edgeless Rubisco which is c4 actually
fits these specs and in the model it
will give you about a seventy percent
gain for no increase in nitrogen if you
could replace the lower canopy Rubisco
with a further different rubisco you
could get up to thirty percent gain well
when we did that that all seemed a bit a
pie in the sky because Rubisco 'he's
coded for in both the plastered and the
nucleus extremely difficult to put into
higher plants but this is a picture from
the paper in nature from Maureen's group
and Martin perry's and rothamsted where
they've really shown you can take very
distant rubisco 'he's get them into
tobacco and at least you can get the
plants to survive two to flowering so so
these things are becoming as the
technology moves forward these things
are becoming more and more possible
finally I just wanted to sort of point
out you can also apply this type of
evolutionary algorithm at the canopy
level and Darren Drury working with me
as a postdoc did this with again soybean
canopy
and I won't go into all the details of
this but basically what he showed was
that you could by changing canopy leaf
reflectivity the angles of the leaves
optimizing those and also the number of
leaves you could get quite a significant
gain in carbon uptake you could also for
warmer environments you could call the
canopy as well and so and we know now
some of the genes for example that
determine hinging of leaves so these
things are becoming possibilities we can
tie them in with phytochrome responses
promoters for phytochrome responses so
they do a different thing at the top of
the canopy to the bottom of the canopy
now one of the things that predicted was
that actually soybeans produced too many
leaves that if if they invested in fewer
leaves you will get more gain and so of
course we were thinking of what what
genotype might be available in which we
could test this venkat the graduate
student who's working with us at the
time was an engineer he done the
modeling so he wasn't in on the
conversations we had about genotypes
instead he started Nick's replicated
experiment in the field where he cut off
every fourth emerging leaf so that he
was preventing the plant from investing
in these extra leaves and what he found
was that sorry every third developing
leaf what he got was a significant ten
percent increase in yield there seem to
be two reasons for that one is that the
canopy actually has more lit more leaves
than it really needs so it it's
respiratory load by having extra leaves
actually outweighs the gain of more
leaves but of course in an evolutionary
sense this might be beneficial because
you never know when a herbivores going
to come along and remove half of what
you've got
but in the farmer's field as a
disadvantage the other is by cutting
them off early you prevent the plant
from investing resource in that
developing leaf and it resulted in a an
increase in yield and we've done that
two years running now so it's involves
quite a lot of undergraduate time as
well what but um he also we had a field
a simulation chamber where we could
actually test out the idea that it
really is resulting in a higher net co2
uptake as well as a high yield so as I
mentioned yesterday with with gates
foundation funding now but my a chance
to test many of these ideas in the field
and so to summarize I think there is a
very serious problem that we're
potentially going to have a shortfall in
primary foodstuffs there you know there
are arguments against that but I don't
think we should be taking chances we
should prepare we should be ensuring
ourselves against an uncertain future
both in human behavior and in climate
driven by that that the potential yield
increases of rising co2 are not fully
realized in our current crops but there
are genetic and biotech solutions
although filled facilities are seriously
lacking to do that we're just not
willing to spend what we need to spend
on on those filled facilities which
which would be a tiny fraction of the
cost we're putting into other things
dear we just spent 100 million near us
drilling into the deep rocks to see if
it could capture a small amount of co2
that that will be enough to pay for
breeding facilities at least three sites
around the country to actually adapt to
these problems
and just again finished by thanking all
the people who've made this possible
ticular i should mention this is jung
mong joo and Donnell my colleagues work
closely with me Lisa R Ainsworth and
andrew lee ki have mentioned as well and
so karl is somewhere in these pictures
but without a phoenician thank you for
attention this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at
cornell.edu